amanda quispe vive un múltiple drama su
hijo tiene cáncer y no recibió
tratamiento oportuno ahora sufre
convulsiones ha perdido la vista y la
memoria como el sistema sanitario
estatal quedó saturado amanda lo interno
en una clínica para salvar su vida hoy
debe más de 127 mil dólares y les dan
por embargar la casa sentimos que son
más discriminados no sentimos que vamos
discriminada no somos escuchados y así
como mini hay un montón de niños y hay
otros que ya no están con nosotros nos
han partido ya han fallecido por por
estar más la atención también en perú
las enfermedades neoplásicas son la
segunda causa de muerte en el país según
cifras oficiales 70.000 nuevos casos se
registran cada año en el mismo período
35.000 peruanos han fallecido por cáncer
la defensoría del pueblo denuncia
escasez de medicamentos y demoras en
tratamientos y cirugías alejandro
escobar paciente con cáncer de próstata
demanda una buena atención en salud si
quisiera que haga por lo menos unos tres
hospitales iguales para poder conservar
a todos nuestros hermanos
que estamos mal
yo quiera
que ante que muera
el ministerio de salud reconoce
deficiencias en atención debido a la
pandemia del cob y 19 el gobierno ha
dispuesto presupuesto para mejorar los
servicios oncológicos sin embargo no
habrá solución a la crisis en el corto
plazo nos va a tomar
aproximadamente 78 años para poder
llegar a los estadios precor y recién en
el año 2030 podremos predecir que
estamos llegando a los escenarios
prepandémica amanda aquí este también
exige que las autoridades atiendan sus
reclamos para evitar la muerte de su
hijo en perú 175 mil personas se esperan
la implementación de la ley nacional del
cáncer que garantice cobertura universal
y oportuna